Speaker 1: All right. I want to show you
another one of these really dumb gas prices
conversations. And I'm so sick of this stuff. And
unfortunately, sometimes the left does it as well.
Former New Orleans Mayor Mitch Landrieu
is now a senior adviser and infrastructure
coordinator to the Biden administration.
He went on Fox News yesterday and was
interviewed by Fox News host Bret Beyer about
gas prices. And they basically just got into
pointing the finger at each other about the same
game that both sides play with gas prices. And
Brett Beyer says to Landrieu, you're giving
Joe Biden credit for the gas prices going down.
But when they went up, you said it was Vladimir
Putin. And Landrieu says to Brett Beyer, well,
you guys on Fox News, when the gas prices went up,
you blame Joe Biden. And now that they go down,
you don't give Joe Biden the credit. And
both are sort of true. And it's part of
what makes this also very stupid things quickly.
Speaker 3: One is that you mentioned that the
president you're giving the president credit for
the gas prices going down. But when they went up,
it was Vladimir Putin and the Ukraine war. Well,
we can say it another way. When it went up,
you guys accused him for making
it happen. And when it went down,
you forgot to give him credit for it. So. Well,
I'm going to go share it with you. It started
going off before the Ukraine war started.
Speaker 1:
Right? It actually started going up before Biden
was even president. Right. I mean, that's that's
the funny thing about it, which is if you the game
that Brett Beyer wants to play is one that ignores
that the gas prices were actually going up under
Trump as well. And in fact, I believe I have the
chart here which I can show you. And if you
take a look at this chart, let's look at the.
Yeah, here it is. So if you look at this in at the
bottom for gas prices was like late April of 2020.
So gas prices go up. In June. And then they go up
and up and up and up. And so the what happened was
that there was a demand collapse during COVID
and then gas prices started going up and then
the Ukraine, Russia war and all these different
things and every country was affected by it. So
Brett Bayer is playing the exact same game here
that they all play. But that that that that is.
Speaker 3: Let me let me say this to the other
thing that's happening is when that when the
price of a barrel goes up, the price
of gas goes up. And when it goes down,
it doesn't go down. And the president called it
out. And we need to work on that, too, because
it's the American people that ought to benefit.
Speaker 1: Okay. Yeah. So you guys get the point.
I mean, I wish that they would just follow
my lead and say, hey, you know what, Brett?
Let's not play these games. Gas prices are
a global issue related to global supply,
and only in a small way do presidents make a
difference on oil, on gas prices. And by the way,
in the United States, we have extremely cheap gas
compared to other countries in the United States,
we don't accurately price a gallon of
gas to actually reflect the true costs,
including the environmental costs. It's
subsidized. The entire thing is a joke. And,
you know, if it were me, we should be moving to
electric vehicles. But I know that that's not
exactly what they can say at every opportunity,
but they're both correctly pointing to the fact
that the other side plays the exact same game.
Abandon it. Do what I've done since George W Bush.
Gas prices up under Bush doesn't really have
much to do with Bush. Gas prices down under Bush
doesn't really have much to do with Bush, although
he actually did invade Iraq, which at least has
some connection to oil. That is more than what any
other president could could actually be could be
attributed to other presidents. With Obama when
the gas prices were extraordinarily low, I said
it's nice, I guess, for drivers, but it doesn't
really have anything to do with Barack Obama.
Same thing under Trump and this is what you get.
Nobody wins from this conversation. They each try
to make their political point. They each try to
say the other side is playing a political game
and they're all it's all true. They're all
doing it. But we learn absolutely nothing.